this is what dreams are made of the
lizzie mcguire reboot is
no longer what dreams are made of
hillary duff revealed on wednesday that
the show is no longer happening
in this lengthy instagram post partially
writing quote i know the efforts and
conversations have been everywhere
trying to make a reboot work
but sadly and despite everyone's best
efforts
it isn't going to happen i want any
reboot of lizzie to be honest and
authentic to who lizzie would be today
it's what the character deserves a
disney spokesperson also confirmed they
are not moving forward with a planned
series nothing could be more superficial
demeaning and shallow
turns out we're not the only ones who
are missing our girl lizzy
many celebs hit the comments to express
they're pretty bummed too
hillary's younger co-star sutton foster
her husband matthew coma
who wrote free lizzy and game of thrones
star sophie turner
she screamed no lizzy no
this news comes after the series hit a
snag in february when hillary hinted
that she wanted the show to be moved
from disney plus
to hulu in an effort to gear the show to
older audiences
i think it's really going to be fun to
go on on the journey with her at 30
and you know it's the same lizzy but
she's an adult and and i think for me
that's a little challenging shooting
because
i have that muscle memory of that like
awkward frantic kind of teenager
and so making choices where i'm like
wait wait she wouldn't say that she's
30. she can't do that now like um
it's it's definitely fun and a little
challenging and also so familiar at the
same time
the show was also put on hold at one
point when the creator and executive
producer of the show
left you know we were having a lot of
fun and it's
it just feels very surreal e.t was the
first to break the news that a lizzie
reboot was happening
you recently said that you would love to
revisit lizzie mcguire
have there been any conversations yes
yes conversations and last fall she
shared tons of fun details with us
she has a lot of those things she
has gained a lot of confidence and she
has
a really cool career and you know she's
still
i think she's still going to be faced
with challenging things
where in middle school those challenging
things seemed funny
and simple but relatable at the time and
i think now in your 30s it's gonna be
the same way but it's like slightly
heavier slightly bigger
things to deal with like she doesn't
have kids yet and she you know she
there's some surprises in the first
episode that i also don't want to give
away
animated lizzy does she have an updated
look
oh i'm like am i giving stuff away i
don't know she's gonna
she's gonna stay the same she's gonna
say that yeah which i think is
is the right thing to do right it's like
that pink top it's so iconic and like
platform flip-flops yeah those like
rocket dog flip-flops i don't know if
anyone knows those
um but yeah she has an epic return
and i'm i'm so excited for everyone to i
think
she's really going to be a lot of the
comic relief in the show
you